[Music]
Hannah brown joins the BTS army the
former bachelorette and partner Alan
Burstyn earned rave reviews from the
judges for their tango during boy band
and girl group night while dancing to
bts's hit boy with love honestly I am
this is the first time I heard this song
and now what you hug the song but yet
they're I mean they're amazing at what
they do they're great dancers great
performers and kind of like that that
big boy band that we have of our time
right now next up the semi-finals and
Hannah admits the pressure is on what do
you want something so bad that there is
going to be that pressure honestly I
think we both are trying to like really
soak in the time that we have used and
we have two more weeks left hopefully
two weeks left and just enjoyed it more
hard times Hannah also opened up about
her big People's Choice win for
competition contestant of 2019 and being
in a room with her two exes Tyler
Cameron and Colton Underwood we're
always kind of together anyway cuz
bachelor nation is such a family stuff I
mean it was it was great but I'm really
glad that I got to take him to win
[Music]